- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is tackle some word
problems involving ratios.
So here, we're told that Yoda Soda
is the intergalactic party drink
that will have all of your
friends saying, mm, good this is.
You are throwing a party
and you need five liters of
Yoda Soda for every 12 guests.
If you have 36 guests,
how many liters of Yoda Soda do you need?
So pause this video and try
to figure it out on your own.
Well, they tell us the
ratio of liters of soda
to number of guests.
So you need five, it's five liters
for every 12 guests is the ratio
but we wanna have 36 guests.
So if the ratio is five liters
of soda for every 12 guests
but we're in a situation
where we have 36 guests,
so this is three times as many guests,
we're gonna need three times
as many liters of soda.
So three times five is 15.
Five to 12.
Five liters for 12 guests
or for five liters for every 12 guests
is the same thing as 15
liters for every 36 guests.
So to answer that question,
how many liters do you need,
you need 15 liters.
Let's do another one of these.
Here, we just have a picture
of a bunch of fish in a tank
and it says there are eight big fish
for every blank small fish
and then it says there are four big fish
for every blank small fish.
So pause this video again
and see if you can work through this.
Alright, so let's just
count the big fish first.
So there's one, two, three,
wait, let me count this way.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
So in this tank, there
actually are eight big fish
and so let's see how many
small fish there are.
There's one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10 small fish.
So in the tank, for every eight big fish
which you see in red,
there are 10 small fish
but here it says, there are four big fish
for every blank small fish.
So what would that be?
Well, one way to think about it
is we have half as many fish
or half as many big fish
so we divided it by two.
So we're gonna have
half as many small fish.
So we're gonna divide by two.
So for every four big fish,
there are five small fish
and one way to think about it,
you could divide the fish evenly
into two groups right over here.
So let's see, if we can capture,
so if you could have, this is,
if I divide it like that,
here I have one, two, three, four big fish
and one, two, three, four, five small fish
then in this group I have
one, two, three, four big fish
and one, two, three,
four, five small fish.
So every four big fish,
there are five small fish.
These are equivalent ratios.
Let's keep going.
So here, we're told an ice cream shop
uses the following ingredients
to make one sundae.
So they use two scoops of ice cream,
four spoonfuls of sprinkles,
two tablespoons of whipped cream.
How many sundaes did the shop make
if they used 32 spoonfuls of sprinkles?
So pause the video and
try to think about it.
So there's a couple of
ways to think about it.
Here, it says, let's see,
we're talking about sprinkles.
So that's what's relevant here.
Four spoonfuls for every one sundae.
So we could say that there,
so the ratio of spoonfuls
to sundaes is four to one.
Four spoonfuls, spoonfuls of sprinkles,
let me write it this way,
let me write sprinkles, sprinkles.
How many spoonfuls?
How many spoonfuls for one sundae?
But here we're talking about
using 32 spoonfuls of sprinkles
so that is eight times as many.
So you're going to be able to use,
create eight times as many sundaes.
So you're gonna have 32
spoonfuls of sprinkles
for every eight sundaes.
So how many sundaes did the shop make?
Well, they made eight.
Let's do one last example.
At a dog park, there are 10 black dogs,
five brown dogs, two white
dogs and 12 multi-color dogs.
For every one brown dog,
there are two blank dogs.
Pause the video and figure
out what goes in this blank.
Alright, so let's see.
There's five brown dogs
for every 10 black dogs,
five brown dogs for every two white dogs
and five brown dogs for
every 12 multi-color dogs
but here you're saying
for every one brown dog,
there are two blank dogs.
So what type of dog is there a ratio?
So for every brown dog,
there's twice as many of that type of dog.
Well, here, we see for
every five brown dogs,
there are 10 black dogs.
So one way to think about it,
the number of black dogs
is always gonna be twice
the number of brown dogs.
So for every one brown dog,
there would be two, two
black, two black dogs.
One way to think about it,
the ratio between brown
dogs and black dogs
and it's kinda counterintuitive.
I used the wrong colors here.
I should have used brown and black.
So let me do that.
So the ratio of brown to black
is five brown dogs for
every 10, 10 black dogs
or if you divide both of
these numbers by five,
you would get one, one brown dog
for every two, for every two black dogs
and that's exactly what
this statement is saying.